à l'été 2000 22 c'est l'objectif de la
mise en service de la ligne 13 du
tramway en cours de construction dans
les yvelines
un projet de longue date qui a pris six
mois de retard à cause de la crise
sanitaire
il reliera les communes de saint cyr
l'école et saint germain en laye en 30
minutes
la première rame est arrivé sur le site
de maintenance de versailles ce samedi
se trame à tout le confort avec des
prises usb la vidéoprotection l'ensemble
des éléments et il est 100% accessible
donc c'est vraiment un tramway qui
apportera une qualité et un confort pour
les usagers au quotidien d'une longueur
de 42 mètres les rames seront également
dotés de la climatisation
dix autres rames seront livrées d'ici
l'été prochain chacune pourra contenir
250 et en voyageur avec 95 places
assises nous tenions à ce que les
yvelines et leur tramway
pourquoi parce que les tramways c'est la
transition écologique c'est la
possibilité de se déplacer à l'intérieur
des yvelines sans prendre sa voiture et
aujourd'hui cette possibilité elle n'est
quasiment pas possible sauf en bus avec
des temps de trajet qui sont extrêmement
longs donc là on va faire en une demi
heure
saint cyr saint germain en laye et puis
dans la phase 2 on ira jusqu à poissy et
hr donc ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
qu'on va pouvoir enfin traverser les
yvelines
sans prendre sa voiture la région
ile-de-france estime entre 20000 pour le
premier tronçon et jusqu'à 40 mille
voyageurs
lorsque l'ensemble de la ligne 13 sera
en service